Okay, this is going to be a super fun and short story because not a lot is known about Vexus syndrome.
And I'm just going to tell a short story about potential IRAC1-4 inhibition in inflammation and how that might contribute to a decrease in inflammatory myelobresis, which seems to be the theme this session.
So Vexus stands for vacuoles E1 ligase enzyme X-linked autoinflammatory and somatic.
It's a relatively new condition that was discovered and or described rather by David Beck in the New England Journal of Medicine in 2020 after studying a cohort of Caucasian men at the NIH with a interesting constellation of autoinflammation, autoimmunity.
And.
And so the syndrome now is sort of classified by a combination of systemic and organ specific autoinflammation and autoimmunity.
The most common manifestations are seen on that plot on the left there.
The most common ones are rashes, vasculitis, both small, medium and large vessel, pleuritis, myocarditis and polychondritis.
If you are affecting the nose and the ears, there's about a 40 to 60 percent penetration in developing overlapping MDS or an MD like MDS like syndrome manifested by cytopenias, severe cytopenias, transfusion dependency and bone marrow failure.
It first presents by macrocytic anemia and occasionally you can find a UBA1 driven MGUS or multiple myeloma.
Although that's more rare since discovering this new syndrome, UBA1 has made it onto MGS panels in the U.S. and across the world widely allowing increased detection of these mutant variants.
And so the mutation canonical UBA1 mutations are in the UBA1 gene and the most common mutations are found at cold on number 41 where the methionine is mutated to a 3-neon valine.
And.
This results essentially in increased expression of this UBA1C that's seen at the bottom, which is catalytically inert and cytoplasmic rather than shuttling between the nucleus and the cytoplasmic as the wild type enzyme functions.
And so the cytoplasmic mutant, because it's catalytically inert, are not able to put ubiquitin molecules onto its target.
And so the cytoplasmic mutant, because it's catalytically inert, are not able to put ubiquitin molecules onto its target protein, thereby decreasing ubiquitination of proteins that should be targeted for degradation and turnover.
And since the description of Vexus, there are numerous non-canonical UBA1 mutant variants being discovered.
Some are actually germline and more and more women being impacted by this syndrome are also being discovered.
And so to lean into, if you will.
The inflammatory auto-inflammatory or inflammation phenomenon that we see in people, starting with cloning metabases, which gains inflammation as people age and of which some transform into MDS and AML.
A lot of inflammatory cytokines are made, including IL-6, TNF, IL-1 beta, IL-12, IL-1 RA there.
And I haven't seen data on IL-1 rep.
But I don't doubt that some of these are also being made in Vexus patients.
And so how does this happen?
Well, it just turns out that we recognize more and more so hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells actually express toll-like receptors.
They probably function in sensing innate immunity pathogens and may drive clonal expansion as we age.
So toll-like receptor and IL-1 receptor signaling require.
There's ubiquitination of negative regulatory proteins for these activation pathways.
And so downstream from toll-like receptors is mighty 88, which then turns on IL-1, IRAC-1, IRAC-4, and that in turn turns on NX-kafa-B, MAP kinase, P38, and drives a lot of pro-inflammatory cytokine production.
And this pathway is turned off by a variety of enzymes that add ubiquitin.
And two, IRAC-1 and 4, for example, and allows for it to be targeted to the proteasome for degradation.
And that's how cells in our body senses inflammation, pathogens, and turn off an appropriate immune response.
A variety of methods have been tried since the discovery of this syndrome.
Primarily, these patients are highly steroid sensitive, but you can't get them off of steroids.
They get stuck about 15 to 20 milligrams of daily steroids, below which they will tell you if they can feel if they're coming.
A variety of disease-modifying anti-rheumatic drugs to shut down the cytokine signaling has been tried, including JAK kinases, any of the anti-cytokine therapies.
But these seem to be ineffective, mostly, and increases infection risk.
The most interesting data that was presented at ASH,
last year, is a study that was done by the French group, as the French VEX,
which stands for the French VEXIS investigation group.
This group looked at, retrospectively, 88 patients, 80% of which meets the WHO criteria for MDS for diagnosis,
and looked at inflammatory responses, RFS, and molecular burden by UBA1.
And as you can see,
that AZA was better compared to the other anti-inflammatory cytokines, including JAK-FE,
at decreasing inflammatory states, measured by CRP, ESR, and a variety of cytokines.
The RFS was actually quite impressive compared to the prior steroid and anti-inflammatory treatments
for a disease with pretty high mortality, at 40 to 50%.
So the RFS was 90% at one year and hadn't been really seen before and stayed stable.
Indicating it may be a durable response as far out as five years.
A lot of these folks achieved RBC and platelet transfusion independence.
And I think the most important is that using azacitidine,
you actually saw a decrease in the molecular burden of UBA1.
And that means that it could be disease-modifying.
And I think most excitingly, you know, 43% of these patients actually decreased their variant.
And the other thing that I would say is that if you take an antidepressant,
you're going to see a decrease in blood pressure.
You're going to see a decrease in the blood pressure.
And so you're going to see a decrease in the blood pressure.
And you're going to see a decrease in the blood pressure.